for today's interview we are going back
to just a classic good old-fashioned
conspiracy theory interview with Jim
Garrow I don't even want to take the
time to reacquaint to you who this guy
is because we do it in the interview a
lot of people lately have been saying I
should interview this guy because he's
completely off his rocker well we did
interview him back in June of 2014 and I
present to you the interview with Jim
Garrow now endlessly endlessly
fascinating I'm joined today by dr. Jim
Garrow who is a lifelong educator
political operative activist really a
man who has worn many hats as literally
as the case today he does join us
wearing a hat
dr. Garrow it's really great to have you
on you know I've been following many of
your interviews on the internet and so
on for many years and you have such an
interesting and storied past and I'm
curious if we take a step back I I would
love to know how you first became so
politically active in your life oh wow
early on I was quite the socialist quite
the Marxist went to university of course
wearing that hat but very quickly came
into the knowledge that socialism is a
religious disbelief and it goes nowhere
so my actively involved political life
really came as a result of growth I'll
call it growth so let's get into some of
your views I've read some things of
yours where you've said that you were an
employee of one of the alphabet agencies
of the US government I don't know if
you've made specific which one but what
why is it that that's been a claim
that's been called into question by some
whether or not you worked for and I
don't know if it's the CIA or the FBI
the D if you want to tell us certainly
I'm open to hearing that but why is that
a claim that some don't believe I don't
know I you know some people don't
believe in Santa Claus in spite of the
fact that I'm sitting here I'm kidding
of course whether someone believes
something or not is not up to me that's
what
they bring to the table not what I bring
if they knew me as a person now they
might believe it but because they don't
I mean people just believe all sorts of
things right no they do but is it true
that your position has been that the
President had you fired from that agency
because you revealed the president's
litmus test for being a US military
officer is that accurate I'd suggest
that that's true okay so you worked for
one of the alphabet agencies and again
we I don't know if it's CIA FBI whatever
the case may be and in the last few
years
President Obama upon finding out that
you revealed that he has a litmus test
for military officers had you fired
yes I'd suggest that that would be the
the way it went yeah I exposed what he
had been doing in questioning his senior
level officers at the request by the way
of one of those senior level officers
who had retired and because they weren't
giving the proper answer to his question
which would be that they have fealty to
him first and foremost above and beyond
the Constitution in the rule of law
frankly then they were either they were
they would be dismissed or pushed out or
forced into early retirement whatever
and do you claim that since that firing
that President Obama has also tried to
have you killed yes I I believe that
given what I know about operations that
what happened to me and my vehicle was
very much intervention on the part of
someone and I can't think of anyone else
who would like to have me dead so let's
talk about that what happened to your
vehicle if it's if it's possible to sum
it up kind of concise quite quickly
there were seven different drilling
drilled holes into a part of the
mechanism of the vehicle and an
injection of some sort of a liquid into
it which would have had there been
enough heat press
and caused the whole thing to cease and
melt really causing an end over end this
kind of emotion so where exactly were
the holes on the vehicle I can't
actually tell you that I promised the
police they wouldn't share this sort of
detail so let me see if I understand
when this happened was this in Canada or
in the u.s. this in Canada in Canada so
you go to your vehicle and how do you
notice that there are holes
strategically drilled in a vehicle you
didn't notice I didn't at all no I
started driving headed toward a meeting
I'd received a phone call from someone
who said that they were a fan yeah this
guy do you normally do that in other
words is it normal for you to get calls
from a fan and just go out and meet them
no not at all so what was what he
convinced you somehow I see okay all
right I thought the details you know he
was going this way and didn't know you
know with the area that I lived in and
would I mind meeting him sure I'm sure
I'm not doing anything right now I was
gonna go up for coffee really this
sounds more fun so you get in the car
and then what happens well then I I
headed down toward the ramp to get on
the highway the major highway and going
around the ramp there was a funny noise
no hear I should point this out that
over over the course of three hours the
temperature here dropped 30 degrees it
was just an amazing turn of events where
the temperature went plummeting so it
went from cool to really frigid right
very quickly that saved my life because
that then caused the element that was
introduced to to the vehicle to not
operate the way they had planned it to
to work and it caused a funny noise and
as soon as I hear funny noises in my
cars I pull over so I pulled over and my
security team arranged for a tow truck
to come and so let's talk about that so
what is you have a security team and
were they in the vehicle with you I'm
actually I can't tell you whether they
were in the vehicle or they were in
other vehicles so there was a security
team okay
and then you guys pull over the security
team arranges for a tow truck and then
at what point do you ascertain that
these holes have been drilled into these
strategic parts of the car when we took
it to a garage to have it looked at and
they headed up on the hoist they
immediately called me and said you need
to see what has been done to your car
okay and I went down and you know one of
my security guys knows a little bit
about tampering and we called the police
and the police upon arriving asked you
not to discuss the details of where the
holes were drilled what what they were
looking at what they are observing was a
very professional job and what they
didn't want was once they realized what
it was they brought in someone else from
another Police Force who would know more
about this sort of activity and that
person said to them this was a very very
professionally well done attempt and
what was the explanation for why in
other words you seemed comfortable
telling me specifically that holes were
drilled and a substance was injected but
the police didn't want you telling me or
anyone where the holes were drilled how
do you explain that level of specificity
from the police about what you can and
can't talk about well they they didn't
exactly get that specific that just said
they didn't want the details out there
and okay what I you know please not and
so you know I'm giving you what I think
is sufficient detail for you to get the
idea can you tell us what the element
that was injected was no you kid that
definitely would be off the table
yes it would okay and then what
connection can we draw to President
Obama and his involvement in this in
other words what evidence do we have for
that part no evidence okay that's what I
thought
so why do you think that that connection
exists well there aren't so many people
who would like to see me dead who would
be able to hire somebody who has is
obviously a professional and I hope if
they were really professionals dr.
Garrow
if
they were truly professionals wouldn't
they have done this in a way that didn't
maybe depend on the temperature not
dropping 30 degrees as you stated
wouldn't they have had a truly
professional method of knocking you off
no if you think about it yeah who would
who would know that there would be a
temperature drop of 30 degrees well what
that's exactly my point in other words
since you don't know that that would
happen wouldn't they come up with a
method of killing you President Obama
that is that wouldn't be subject to a
temperature drop throwing it off if
you're hired as a specialist who does a
particular thing do you suddenly change
your modus operandi I don't think so so
this person was hired I guess with the
knowledge that that's the kind of thing
he did all right
and dr. Garrett what kind of a doctor
are you for people who might be
wondering HD and family marriage therapy
if you go around and sorry I'm just
looking up this is my office here you
know I members a member of all sorts of
organizations American school counselors
Association American counseling
Association American Association of
School Psychologists
you know lots of different counseling
organizations good know I think it's
just good to get that on the record in
the limited time we have left I do want
to touch about on I know you you believe
that President Obama tried to kill you
but you've also claimed that President
Obama ordered the deaths of conservative
blogger Andrew Breitbart I believe the
Rolling Stone journalist michael
hastings and the fiction author tom
clancy why do you think that they had to
be knocked off by president obama well
they were working together with tom
providing him with information some some
of it was unknown to the public and
still is unknown to the public about
barack obama the essence of the novel
itself was going to be about a man who
was groomed to become the president of
the United States paid for bought and
paid for by oil interests and Muslims
generally so if I understand because I
don't want my audience to miss the
details here
andrew breitbart and michael hastings
together were providing novelist tom
clancy with secret information about
president obama which tom clancy was
then going to turn into a novel which in
reality would have exposed some pretty
damaging stuff about president obama so
president obama wanted to have them all
killed okay yeah and keep in mind that
these staging the the staggering of
events here is not like it all happened
all at once no I know yeah yeah yeah
you're right that's basically my
contention yeah of course it's my
contention but then I was also chatting
with all three of them and knew some of
the details so yeah all I have to say is
this so you you assert that you were in
touch with Breitbart michael hastings
and tom clancy around this issue or they
were in touch with me oh okay well
that's a little more mysterious all
right hey this is i'm fascinated by this
dr. Garrow I must admit last thing is
this entire interview you've been
completely honest and upfront this is
not in any way an act joke parody or
anything these are your truly sincerely
held beliefs about reality right this
part of reality yes absolutely all right
well this is dr. Garrow if at some point
you're willing to tell us more about
that security detail of yours I would
love to know more about it so it's an
open invitation that's a topic that at
anytime we would love to talk more about
all right thank you
[Music]